Marvel's Hulk might be the strongest there
is, but he's not invincible.
The big green guy and his human alter ego,
Bruce Banner, have battled heroes and villains
alike since his debut in 1962.
And while Hulk may be the strongest, it's
only natural that he's still taken a few big
losses along the way.
Here are some of the more notable fights that
go in the Hulk's L column.
But, just one warning to those who've given
the Hulk a decisive beatdown: he always comes
back angry — and you wouldn't like him when
he's angry.
Thor
In 2001's Incredible Hulk Annual, Thor, fresh
off of a battle of his own, decides to help
local authorities stop the Hulk's rampage.
The Asgardian equivalent of a sucker-punch
— a thunderbolt straight to Hulk's face
— gives Thor an early edge, but the brawl
continues across multiple dimensions before
a winner emerges.
Ultimately, however, it's Thor's biology,
not his battle prowess, that puts him ahead.
While the Hulk is distracted by local wildlife,
Bruce Banner takes control of the Hulk's body.
However, the otherworldly atmosphere doesn't
have enough oxygen for a regular human, and
Banner passes out, leaving Thor victorious.
Deadpool
It's hard to believe, but in one of Deadpool's
very first solo appearances, he picked a one-on-one
fight with the Hulk.
And won.
In 1997’s Deadpool #4, Wade Wilson learns
that his healing factor is breaking down,
and if that goes, the cancer that plagues
his body will make a quick and fatal return.
Even worse, there's only one cure: a sample
of the Hulk's gamma-irradiated blood.
Tracking down the Hulk is easy.
Getting a sample of his blood isn't.
Deadpool's swords don't make much of a dent
in the Hulk's thick green hide, and Deadpool
doesn't stand a chance in a straight-up brawl.
But Deadpool's not just crazy — he's also
smart.
When the Hulk leaps straight towards him,
Deadpool points an old broken pipe right at
the charging beast.
Hulk impales himself, and Deadpool collects
a blood sample from the monster's bleeding
wound before the Hulk can recover.
Eventually, the Hulk frees himself by pulling
the pipe out of the ground, but not before
Deadpool makes an extremely speedy getaway.
Juggernaut
Cain Marko, better known as the Juggernaut,
has super-strength and super-endurance.
But his most notable power is that once he's
in motion he's literally unstoppable.
That ability came in pretty handy in The Incredible
Hulk #402, when the Hulk took over a government
agency called the Pantheon and immediately
headed to South America on a peacekeeping
mission.
There, Hulk ran into a casually dressed Juggernaut,
who immediately launched an attack.
Hulk spent most of the fight distracted — he
didn't recognize Marko in everyday clothes
— and yet seemed to have the Juggernaut
put away when Marko sank in a pit of quicksand.
But nothing can stop the Juggernaut, not even
Mother Nature.
Juggernaut burst out of the trap, put Hulk
in a sleeper-hold, and went on to beat the
stuffing out of his opponent.
Batman
That's right: Batman went toe-to-toe with
the Hulk, and claimed victory in the process.
It all happened in DC Special Series #27,
an intercompany crossover that came out in
September of 1981.
Using a false identity, Bruce Banner sneaks
into a job at Wayne Enterprises, which was
manufacturing a brand new gamma radiation
gun.
Banner hoped the device could get rid of the
Hulk once and for all, but before he could
find out, the Joker attacked.
Bruce hulked out just as Batman arrived, and
it wasn't long before they were duking it
out in a Wayne Research laboratory.
That the two of them would get into a fight
isn't surprising.
What is surprising is the simplicity of Batman's
plan: a pellet of sleeping gas and a well-timed
kick to the gut, and the Hulk goes down.
And that wouldn't be the last time the Hulk
faced off against a member of Marvel's distinguished
competition...
Superman
In 1996, the DC and Marvel universes squared
off in a four-part miniseries appropriately
called DC vs. Marvel.
One of the series' best gimmicks was that
it gave fans the ability to vote on who would
win in each superpowered showdown.
While the Marvel Universe ended up on top
once the dust cleared, when Superman beat
the Hulk at the polls, he laid the smack down
on the printed page as well.
It's not even close.
While the Hulk lands a few good punches, a
heat-vision barrage and a well-placed strike
to the jaw is all that the Last Son of Krypton
needs to put him down.
The only silver lining for Hulk fans?
The version of the Hulk featured in DC vs.
Marvel had previously traded some of his strength
in order to keep Bruce Banner's intellect.
But if the Hulk had been at full power?
Maybe it would've been a different story...
Hawkeye
If the Hulk has a weakness, it's Bruce Banner.
The easiest way to put down the jade giant
is to stop Banner before he transforms.
That's how Hawkeye deals with the Hulk in
Marvel's mega-event series Civil War II.
When a young man named Ulysses prophesies
a Hulk-fueled disaster, superheroes gather
on Bruce Banner's doorstep and ask the scientist
to turn himself in.
Before Banner can comply, however, Hawkeye
— who claims that he saw Banner's eyes flash
green — lets loose an arrow, killing Banner
instantly.
But, for what it’s worth, Banner did ask
him to do it if he ever felt he might hurt
innocent people.
So...hooray for the good guys?
The Hulk
In the Future Imperfect storyline, the Hulk
takes on his own worst enemy — the Hulk.
And as you might guess, it doesn't go so well.
Set about 100 years in the future, Future
Imperfect explores a world where war has wiped
out heroes and villains alike.
The Hulk, now calling himself the Maestro,
rules the world with an iron fist, thanks
to a combination of Bruce Banner's intelligence,
nuclear-powered strength, and a century's
worth of pent-up rage.
Rebels use a time machine to bring the present-day
Hulk into the future, hoping that the strongest
one there is can stop a warlord who's even
stronger.
Unfortunately, the Maestro knows all of the
Hulk's moves and then some, and easily defeats
his younger counterpart, ultimately snapping
the Hulk's neck.
The Hulk eventually recovers and confronts
the Maestro again, and while he still can't
physically defeat the despot, he does end
up winning.
Using the same time machine that propelled
him into the future, Hulk sends the Maestro
back to the gamma explosion that created him
in the first place.
The Maestro is incinerated at the exact same
time the Hulk is born, leading to a victory
for the good guys — and two decisive Hulk
beatdowns in one epic story.
Now if that's not epic enough for you, strap
yourself in for the Hulk's most diabolical
foe yet.
That's right, we're going to talk about the
time the Hulk was defeated by...
Puppies
Over the years, S.H.I.E.L.D.
has tangled with the Hulk numerous times,
and as one of the most important and technologically
advanced peacekeeping agencies on the planet,
it only makes sense that they'd put that experience
to good use.
In 2013's The Indestructible Hulk Special,
S.H.I.E.L.D.
unleashed its latest, greatest, and cutest
anti-Hulk weapon: a crate crammed full of
puppies.
See, while the Hulk might be a monster, he's
not heartless.
The onslaught of adorable little furballs
eased the Green Goliath's nerves and forced
a transformation back into the Hulk's mild-mannered
alter-ego, Bruce Banner.
Not very scientific, but it got the job done.
So the next time you're facing off against
a giant, green rage monster, don't forget
to bring a couple of cute doggos along.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!